you knew when you're very young and
you're getting started in the business
you were an in acting class with Marilyn
Monroe is that true that's true
did you hang out with her at all I
walked heard from 58th Street to the
Actors Studio
and she didn't say much but she didn't
have to and walking along and I said you
don't this is amazing Marilyn because
nobody's you know falling apart here
because you're walking along people
weren't recognized they didn't recognize
I said how come they don't jump up and
down and she said oh do you want to see
her I want sure and so all she did was
just to throw her shoulders back you
know I tried that all the time nothing
happened like that and she she started
walking along within 20 feet it was
surrounded by about 40 people Wow
so she could become Marilyn Monroe like
that yeah yeah and I I liked her so much
she liked her because he was so real and
sweet and kind all those things besides
being gorgeous yeah and a few other
things
you